>>> RUSS'S PUTIN HAS TAKEN HIS
OBSESSION TO THE SOVIET GLORY
DAY TO A NEW LEVEL.
STAGING A MASSIVE PROPAGANDA
RALLY ON FRIDAY.
SEVERAL RUSSIANS TELL CNN THAT
AUTHORITIES PRESSURED PEOPLE TO
ATTEND THE EVENT, WHICH WAS
MEANT TO COMMEMORATE THE EIGHTH
ANNIVERSARY OF RUSSIA'S TAKEOVER
OF CRIMEA.
HERE TO DISCUSS IS A RUSSIAN
OPPOSITION POLITICIAN WHO
SURVIVED TWO POISONINGS IN
RUSSIA.
AT THIS RALLY, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US BY THE WAY, WE
APPRECIATE IT.
AT THIS RALLY, PUTIN JUSTIFIED
THE INVASION OF UKRAINE AS HE
STOOD IN FRONT OF A BANNER THAT
READ FOR A WORLD WITHOUT
NAZIISM.
AGAIN, WITH THIS NAZI TALK, IT
IS SO TERRIFYING BECAUSE IT IS
SO DERANGED THAT SO MANY
RUSSIANS ARE BELIEVING THIS
CRAZY NONSENSE.
>> WELL, WHAT WE SAW YESTERDAY,
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST OF ITS
KIND THAT MR. PUTIN HAS STAGED
TO TRY TO SORT OF PUT OUT THIS
FACADE OF SUPPORT THAT HE WANTS
TO CLAIM.
THERE IS SO MUCH IN SORT OF
HARKENING BACK TO NOT ONLY THE
SOVIET PAST AND THE RALLIES THAT
TOOK PART IN THE SOVIET UNION,
THIS MAKES IT DOUBLY
HYPOCRITICAL.
I'D USE THE WORD IRONIC HAD IT
NOT BEEN SO SERIOUS.
SO MUCH OF THE STYLE, SO MUCH OF
THE SUBSTANCE OF WHAT PUTIN'S
REGIME IN RUSSIA NOW REPRESENTS
ACTUALLY HAS ECHOES WITH NAZIISM
IN GERMANY IN THE 1930s.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO, MR. PUTIN
GAVE A SPEECH ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION WHERE WE DESCRIBED
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS INSIDE
OF RUSSIA, PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF
AND MY COLLEAGUES IN THE RUSSIAN
OPPOSITION, AS QUOTE, NATIONAL
TRAITORS.
THIS IS A TERM DIRECTLY BORROWED
FROM HITLER IN GERMANY.
THIS STYLIZED THAT HAS BEEN USED
BY THE KREMLIN PROPAGANDA AS A
SYMBOL OF SUPPORT FOR THIS
AGGRESSION ON UKRAINE.
REALLY DOES LOOK LIKE A
SWASTIKA.
PUTIN'S REGIME ITSELF AS IT SORT
OF TRIES TO MAKE THIS BOGUS AND
OUTRAGEOUS CLAIMS OF SOMEHOW
THEY'RE FIGHTING NAZIS IN
UKRAINE, REQUIRE MORE AND MORE
TRAITS OF A FASCIST REGIME.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OUR
VIEWERS NOT TO BE FOOLED BY THE
SMOKE SCREEN, BY THIS
PROPAGANDA.
PUTIN WOULD LIKE THE WHOLE WORLD
TO THINK THAT ALL RUSSIANS
SUPPORT HIM.
THAT ALL RUSSIANS BACK THIS
CRIMINAL AGGRESSION THAT HE'S
ENGAGING IN WITH REGARD TO
UKRAINE, BUT THAT'S NOT AT ALL
THE CASE.
IN FACT, SINCE THIS ATTACK BEGAN
ON FEBRUARY 24th, THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS RUSSIA HAVE GONE
OUT INTO THE STREETS TO TRY TO
PROTEST, I SAY TRY BECAUSE MOST
OF THEM ARE IMMEDIATELY ARRESTED
AND HERDED AWAY TO POLICE
STATIONS.
IT IS NOW A CRIMINAL OFFENSE IN
RUSSIA, NOT JUST TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST THIS WAR, BUT EVEN TO
CALL IT A WAR.
YOU CAN GET UP TO 15 YEARS IN
PRISON IF YOU CALL WHAT PUTIN IS
DOING IN UKRAINE A WAR.
BUT DESPITE THIS FACT, THERE
HAVE BEEN THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
RUSSIA WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED TO
SAY THIS IS NOT BEING DONE IN
OUR NAME.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
WORLD TO ALSO HEAR THOSE RUSSIAN
VOICES, NOT JUST OF THE PUTIN
PROPAGANDA MACHINE.
>> NO QUESTION.
YOU'RE RIGHT TO RAISE THAT POINT
AND WE HAVE REPORTED ON THIS
EXTENSIVELY.
BUT I HAVE TO ASK YOU HOW DO YOU
THINK IT GOT TO THIS POINT AND
HOW DOES YOUR EXPERIENCE I GUESS
PROVIDE MAYBE A LESSON OR
WARNING SIGN MISSED ALONG THE
WAY?
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH AND WE WERE
TALKING TO THE WIDOW OF A PUTIN
CRITIC WHO WAS POISONED AND
DIED, AND YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH WHAT SHE TOLD US IS
CORRECT.
THERE WERE SO MANY WARNING SIGNS
MISSED, IGNORED BY THE WORLD
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST CONVENIENT
PERHAPS TO LET PUTIN'S
AGGRESSION JUST PASS IN PREVIOUS
EPISODES.
WHAT ARE YOUR THAUGTDS?
>> DON'T EVEN GET ME STARTED ON
THIS.
I CANNOT EXPRESS THE FEELINGS OF
FRUSTRATION AND FRANKLY RAGE
THAT A LOT OF US IN RUSSIA FEEL
THESE DAYS BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO TELL THE WORLD FOR 22
YEARS NOW JUST WHO PUTIN WAS.
IT WASN'T AN ENIGMA, A SECRET.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS HE DID
WHEN HE CAME TO POWER IN THE
YEAR 2000 WAS REINSTATE THE
SOVIET NATIONAL ANTHEM AS THE
ANTHEM OF THE FEDERATION.
THIS IS AS POWERFUL A SYMBOL AS
YOU CAN GET.
EARLY YEARS OF HIS RULE, PUTIN
ENGAGED IN A INTENSIVE CRACKDOWN
AGAINST DEMOCRACY AND CIVIL
SOCIETY INSIDE OF RUSSIA AND
PUSHED THE IMPERFECT DEMOCRACY
WE HAD IN THE '90s TO THE
PERFECT DICTATORSHIP WE HAVE
TODAY.
ONE AFTER ANOTHER, DESTROYING
INDEPENDENT MEDIA.
OPPOSITION PARTIES GOING AFTER
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
IMPRISONING OPPONENTS, THEN
MURDERING OPPONENTS.
WE MARKED THE SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ASSASSINATION
OF ONE WHO WAS GUNNED DOWN IN
FRONT OF THE KREMLIN.
ALL THIS TIME, WESTERN LEADERS
CONTINUED TO SHAKE MR. PUTIN'S
HAND AND INVITE HIM TO HIGH
LEVEL SUMMITS AND TRY TO FIND
WAYS OF DEALING WITH HIM.
LOOKED INTO HIS EYES AND GOT A
SENSE OF HIS SOUL AND DECLARED
RECESS WITH HIM AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH AND THIS IS WHERE WE ARE
TODAY.
FACING A LARGE SCALE WAR IN THE
MIDDLE OF EUROPE.
FACING WAR CRIMES.
WHAT I WOULD ARGUE ARE CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY THAT THE PUTIN
REGIME IS CONDUCTING.
AND THIS WAS SO PREDICTABLE.
THIS IS WHAT'S ENRAGING ABOUT
IT.
THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY THAT THE
APPEASEMENT OF DICTATORS ENDS.
AND WE ARE SEEING THIS NOW.
AND YES, IT IS ALSO THE FAULT
NOT JUST OF THOSE PEOPLE IN
RUSSIA WHO CHOSE TO STAY SILENT
OVER THE YEARS IN THE FACE OF
THE REGRESSIONS BY MR. PUTIN,
BUT THERE'S SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITY BY WESTERN
LEADERS WHO CHOSE TO TURN A
BLIND EYE WHEN PUTIN WAS
DESTROYING DEMOCRACY IN RUSSIA.
>> WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER IN TERMS
OF THE LARGER QUESTION IN ALL OF
THIS, WHICH IS HOW DO WE
EXPEDITE THE END OF PUTIN'S
STRANGLE HOLD ON RUSSIA AND HIS
ATTEMPT TO ESSENTIALLY CONTINUE
TO BULLY THE WORLD?
DO YOU HAVE A CLEAR AND CONCISE
ANSWER THAT I SUPPOSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE COULD AGREE ON?
I GUESS THAT IS PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THERE ARE JUST
SO MANY DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW
AS TO HOW TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
WITHOUT WORLD WAR III BREAKING
OUT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, TO STATE THE
OBVIOUS, ONLY RUSSIANS IN RUSSIA
CAN CHANGE THE SITUATION IN OUR
COUNTRY.
NOBODY'S ADVOCATING ANY KIND OF
REGIME CHANGE FROM THE OUTSIDE.
ONLY RUSSIANS IN RUSSIA CAN
AFFECT POLITICAL CHANGE.
AND THIS WILL HAPPEN AND MR.
PUTIN HAS REALLY ACCELERATED ALL
THESE PROCESSES IN THE LAST FOUR
WEEKS WITH HIS AGGRESSION IN
UKRAINE.
HE'S HAD A LOT OF PROBLEMS,
ESPECIALLY AMONG THE YOUNGER
GENERATION.
THIS MAN HAS BEEN IN POWER FOR
MORE THAN 22 YEARS.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING TIRED OF
SEEING THE SAME FACE ON THE
TELEVISION SCREEN ALL THE TIME.
SO POLITICAL CHANGE CAN ONLY
COME FROM WITHIN RUSSIA ITSELF,
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THE
FREE WORLD, THE COMMUNITY OF
DEMOCRACIES, STANDS IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO SEE A FREE AND
DEMOCRATIC RUSSIA.
A RUSSIA THAT WOULD RESPECT THE
RIGHTS OF OUR OWN PEOPLE AT HOME
AND THAT WOULD ALSO BEHAVE
ITSELF AS A RESPONSIBLE CITIZEN
ON THE INTERNATIONAL STAGE.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT, SHOULD BE
ONE OF THE HIGHEST PRIORITIES
FOR THE WEST RIGHT NOW, TO
PROVIDE THE TRUTH TO THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE IN THE RUSSIAN LANGUAGE
TO OPEN THE EYES OF RUSSIAN
SOCIETY ON THE FAMOUS CRIMES
THAT PUTIN'S COMMITTING ON
BEHALF OF OUR COUNTRY, BECAUSE
AS MIND BOGGLING AS IT SOUNDS,
MANY PEOPLE IN RUSSIA DO NOT
EVEN THOUGH THERE IS A REAL WAR
GOING ON IN UKRAINE.
THEY DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THE
TARGETING OF CIVILIANS, CLUSTER
BOMBINGS, BOMBINGS ON MATERNITY
WARDS.
AS YOU KNOW AND AS YOU'VE
REPORTED, IN THE LAST FOUR
WEEKS, THE SAME TIME HE'S
LAUNCHED AN AGGRESSION AGAINST
UKRAINE, PUTIN HAS ALSO
DESTROYED WHAT REMAINED OF
INDEPENDENT MEDIA INSIDE RUSSIA.
SO THERE'S A TOTAL INFORMATION,
CENSORSHIP AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE FREE WORLD TO
HELP BREACH THAT CENSORSHIP AND
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT NOT TO LET
UP THOSE, ESPECIALLY THOSE
TARGETED SANCTIONS AGAINST THOSE
HIGHER LEVEL OLIGARCHS AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSERS AROUND PUTIN WHO
HAVE FOR YEARS GOTTEN USED TO
BEING ABLE TO STEAL IN RUSSIA
THEN STAND AND STASH AWAY THAT
STOLEN MONEY IN THE WEST AND FOR
SUCH A LONG TIME, THE WEST HAS
ENABLED THIS BEHAVIOR.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS FINALLY STOP
IN THE LAST FOUR WEEKS.
IT HAS TAKEN A WAR IN THE MIDDLE
OF EUROPE TO MAKE IT STOP AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE THE WEST
STAND FIRM.
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
MILLIONS IN RUSSIA WHO WANT OUR
COUNTRY TO BECOME A NORMAL,
MODERN DEMOCRACY.
I HAVE NO DOUBT THIS DAY WILL
COME.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
AS YOU WERE TELLING OUR TEAM, A
CURR